hey guys if you watch the Wednesday show
a fresh and fit you guys remember
Stephanie palomares was getting Dunked
On by the chat the entire show and I
asked Stephanie palomars I said
Stephanie before the show I need you to
screenshot how many only fan subscribers
you have and then afterwards I need you
to tell me how many you have 24 hours
later should we all do that right now
yes I guess we already did it I think
all of you should do that now here's
what happened all the like I've never
seen a girl get dunked on more than this
girl on on on pressure fit ever like
they the whole chat was just on her the
entire time she got 1200 paying Subs in
24 hours guys hold on for those of you
who don't can't do math because you went
to public school that's 12 000 a month
that's
144 000 a year from sitting for sitting
there for two and a half hours getting
Dunked On by the chat and she wrote me
later and she was like yeah it's totally
worth it I would do it again that's what
she told me what are you saying Personal
Fitness Dubai what do you mean I mean
they're going to get dunked on but it's
worth it
Dubai the [__] go there to get shout
out come on
yes that's what I meant again
big announcement we're going on tour
what yes we're on tour what are you
gonna do we're gonna react to videos
live no we're gonna do stand up crack
jokes maybe laugh maybe you don't but
you're going to pay 75 to find out
so
I mean you much better make sure you
guys click the link in description I
think the first couple days we're doing
Detroit we're going to be doing
Washington Pittsburgh and Washington so
those are the three C's we're doing this
late summer end of August and then after
that we're going to be doing the rest of
America we're likely going to go to
Europe some parts we're excited to get
to catch you guys face to face just so
you guys understand this is what what
I'm seeing because I'm trying to be
objective here I am seeing women say
delusional things about the men they're
attracted to on the show and then I see
men calling them 304s and then I see
these same women ending up with
thousands of new Instagram or uh uh only
fan Subs so you guys instead in the chat
instead of coming after me and Rolo you
need to be coming after other dudes in
the chat and asking which one of you
[__] is sitting there saying
this [__] and then subbing to these
girls I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with subbing to these girls what I
am saying is there's something wrong
with calling them [__] and then
subbing to their only fans that's
something that is [__] up that's
kindergarten thing whenever the little
guy is pulling on the hair of a girly
life it's just that it evolved to
dunking on a girl in IMEI this green
nobody sees you so you dunk on that girl
oh you diss you that you that you that
you say it out loud it's funny it makes
a guy laugh but then after that you're
gonna sub to her it's just like back in
my days whenever there was dudes there
was dudes dunking on fat girls all this
and that whatever whatnot they were the
same dudes like going in in in Disguise
yeah [__] trying to ask them out or
whatever what not and hold hands and
chill with them and then when the other
guys show up they were like yo don't
hold my hand that's the same dudes
that's the same dudes they're gonna say
all this [__] but the next step they're
gonna be like yeah this and that and and
these guys are the same dudes they do
the same thing the same Russians do the
same thing they're gonna dunk on all
these girls The Next Step next thing you
know they're gonna go out with them
they're gonna chill with them they're
gonna be like yeah I got a baddie with
me and it's okay that's what they do you
have to understand that that's what they
do and that's what that's what's going
on
that's what's going on because people
always ask the question why would these
women go on this podcast and get hated
on other stuff because it's lucrative
some of them make a lot of money from it
they understand the game it's a game to
them yes it's like you don't you don't
understand how most of those guys who
say that stuff to those women actually
just really felt negatively about
themselves yeah and they just project it
outwardly onto the women but if those
women even showed them a mod upcom of
attention you know they would turn into
Sims so fast so they're doing all this
all these [__] [__] these [__]
[__] the girls like hi he's like uh
hello they don't understand uh man the
thing that happened is that you could
call all these girls [__] and this and
that and whatever what nine in the third
the difference is that they understand
and it's a business
so whenever you go into that high value
[__] and you know make money and stuff
like that and flunk it to a bunch of
girls
basically I said this [__] before all
right if you try to attack if you try to
attract girls with cheese you're gonna
end up with rats you understand what I'm
saying and that's what's going on you're
gonna attract them with all the cheese
and then you're gonna be like that's a
whole all she wants is my money that's
what you showed her
and not the games you're gonna have a
bunch of hustles they're gonna get for
the money and that's the kind of women
you go after it's fine it's and then
you're gonna go younger to get another
one this is a cycle when that girl is
gonna get to a certain nail age you're
gonna dunk her you're gonna dump her
you're gonna be like yeah you know what
whatever what not I'm gonna get myself a
younger one but it's you creating the
cycle basically what you guys are doing
is creating the cycle that you're
[__] on but when you're [__] on
that you really just fertilizing that
[__]
encouraging other men to [__] on that
cycle and then they do the same thing
same guys are going to call you this and
that that's like the New York Paradox
whenever you walk in Brooklyn and stuff
like that yo hey yo ma giving you mad
attention it's just a reverse of that
they [__] on you first and then when
everybody on all the homies is gone
they're gonna sub because the girl is
not gonna be able to know who's who and
who did what and he's gonna be able to
see [__] pictures
that's it it's fine it's just no knowing
what element you're in and these girls
you can call them whatever they want
it's a business to them and as much as
you can call Abba and preach gay you're
the fruit
they're harvesting you
you put in your dollars and it's okay
that you put your dollars the whole
tradcon religious grift is funny too
like the what the whole like adherence
to like religious ideas for this
obsession with [__] yeah the kind of
women who constantly sell their bodies
is like the majority of the people on
these podcasts
it's funny because you would think that
this red pill stuff has been around for
a long time but it seems like for most
of the people involved they still can't
get women they still can't get attention
for women and they still can't meet
their goals and so one of the funniest
moments someone sent me a clip and it's
like they were doing a live podcast and
the audience members showed up and then
they asked them a question uh show of
hands if you're currently in a real
show of hands if you're single
okay oh
[Music]
for all the single dudes out there raise
your hand if you want a girlfriend or a
wife or a girl in your life show of
hands
okay so the most of you want a girl in
your life
show of hands if you want to do the
Myron approach and have multiple wives
okay now [__] who can't get one
girl want to have multiple
it's a goal
it's a gold it's a pipe dream it's a
goal if you want to go to Broadway but
you can't get one audition you still
want to get the Broadway I'll give them
that and this is what I'm saying this
whole ideology is funny because it's
supposed to do all the self-improvement
stuff and it's supposed to get results
but you see most of the people who
attend can't get them and then they have
a pipe dream that's so Out Of Reach it's
like you're not even built for that yeah
all right all this talk about we can
help people getting healthy
relationships and maintain lengthy
marriages and all those other stuff you
realize no because there's a bunch of
men who are living in a delusion of
having a harem right they think they can
just indulge all day long so whether
it's hating on these [__] was whatever
most of the stuff is just smoking
mirrors they don't have any extra real
set goals that are reasonable and they
don't actually have a real view of women
that is actually
functioning in real life they stand
beside a keyboard they go [__] [__]
[__] and then they click on the only
fans to subscribe so all this talk about
being pimps and all this other [__] you
realize that this whole platform is just
to allow men easier access to women so
they can simp harder
all this hating all this talk all this
stuff is really just a reflection of
themselves the reason why they say all
that Fellowship to women is because they
don't feel good about themselves because
any dude who gets women any dude who
likes women it doesn't talk that way so
really a lot of it is just self-loathing
and then that self-loathing is projected
outwardly because you're like I'm
inadequate well [__] these horses it's
their fault rather than take a look in
the mirror and realize something like yo
you know what I wouldn't [__] me either
I wouldn't even look at me either
what have I done to get these women to
be interested in me I just think the
obsession with whoredom is funny to me
when the kind of women these dudes
constantly clamor after subscribe to
Instagrams or pay for only fans are
women with ridiculous butts ridiculous
size inflated balloon titties ridiculous
looking lips everything is surgically
done you know it's interesting that
that's what they hate but then that's
all they jerk off to or is subscribe to
or pay for this is an interesting thing
there that's what they hate but if you
look at the the Instagram search
yeah
that is facts and that's why you see
even regular women who don't even do
stuff online not getting all these
surgeries because they see what these
men are clamoring for
but hey that's the life smoking mirrors
anything else nope
you were never mean to girls in Middle
School
no I couldn't oh no
no no no I couldn't
no not I recall they're definitely done
that huh I definitely done that yeah
yeah but this deserved it
all right
yo bro one time this girl I came to
school one day I got called the
principal's office
and then this girl apparently she I was
like why am I here and they said yo
apparently you destroyed somebody's snow
fort I was like what the [__] you
talking about
they said yeah she this girl came in
crying she said he did it I said what I
was so mad I said I didn't do [__] they
said you could just admit to it we all
know it's you I I I almost start
stomping around all upset and puffing
out my chest
so then I just left and I was like
really mad because I didn't do it I'm
like a date later they called me back in
the office and she was there crying I
was like why is she crying and it turns
out the guy who like does the snow
plowing just ran over a bunch of the
forts so it wasn't you dude you thought
it was me too yeah
yeah no it wasn't me bro a piece of [__]
I don't know why my little inner child
was like yo [__] preach dude [__] that
[__]
I wouldn't have given you my basketball
anyways yeah yeah but yeah
[__] ass that's gay
yeah you guys heard it right or is it
just me oh that's the way you defend
yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
whatever you don't have an argument it's
just all such [__] yeah thanks because
you've been doing some stuff
all right peaches all right cream